(man) the sharks are back,
looking for the best products
and Businesses
America has to offer.
If they hear a great idea,
they're ready to invest
using their own money...
you're insulting us
with an offer of 5%.
I give you a little money,
you give me a little money.
You don't really want to
make a deal here, do you?
And fight each other
for a piece of the action.
You just bumped
your offer up?
You went up?
Yes, I just did.
Wow.
But first, the entrepreneurs
must convince a shark
to invest the full amount
they're asking for,
or they'll walk away
with Nothing.
We have other money
on the table, as well.
If you have money on the table,
why would you be here?
Restaurants don't sell
wine Apparel.
Yet.
Do you feel like your whole life
has led up to this moment?
Who are the sharks?
They're five self-made,
filthy-rich Investors.
Kevin O'Leary
is a venture capitalist
who started a software business
in his basement,
which he eventually sold
for $3.2 Billion.
Barbara Corcoran turned
a $1,000 loan
into a real estate Empire
worth hundreds of millions
in the shark-filled city
of Manhattan.
Daymond John is
a fashion and branding expert
Who grew his homemade hats
and t-shirts
into the globally recognized
fashion brand Fubu.
Robert herjavec, the son
of an immigrant factory worker,
is now a technology mogul
Who sold his first
internet companies
for over $350 million.
And mark cuban, a self-made
billionaire entrepreneur
and the outspoken owner
of the 2011 NBA Champion
Dallas Mavericks.
♪♪
My name is Stephan aarstol.
I'm 39 years old, and I live
in San Diego, california.
I've always been
what you might call a-a geek,
you know, I got good grades,
I was on math team.
I've kind of always played
things by the book.
Coming out of graduate school
with an M.B.A.,
uh, you're sort of groomed to go
in a--a certain direction
Towards really corporate jobs,
management consulting type jobs,
and I-I did it,
but that, uh, just really sucked
the life out of me.
With the set of skills
that I have,
I wanted to do something
different,
you know, I guess I just
didn't know how different.
♪♪
I fell in love
with Stand-up paddling
the first time I tried it.
The more I looked at the sport,
the more I-I just realized
that there was a--
there was
a tremendous opportunity here.
(cheering)
Today is a huge day for me.
I mean, this is the launch of
the brand that I created--
tower paddle boards.
The sport of Paddle boarding is
a lot of fun to just
be involved with in general.
But being in this industry,
th-there's a lot
of sort of fringe benefits,
especially for some of us,
you know, internet geeks.
Whoo!
I hope the sharks really can see
what a huge opportunity this is.
If I can get them to invest
money in this, uh, you know,
I-I never have to go back
to the corporate world again.
Long live tower Paddle boards!
(cheering)
♪♪
My name is Stephan aarstol.
My company is
tower paddle boards.
I'm seeking $150,000 in exchange
for 10% of my company.
What if I told you
the fastest-growing water sport
in the world
was something that each of you
could master
in about 20 minutes?
It's called
stand-up paddle Boarding.
Stand-up paddle Boarding is
absolutely exploding.
It's coming to every beach,
every river,
and every lake in the world.
It's got the cool,
soulful appeal of surfing,
and it's so easy to do
that all of you can do it.
(sighs)
my, uh...
(bleep).
my company is, uh...
don't worry. It's only your
biggest moment in your life.
It's so easy.
Uh, you--you can do it
with your friends.
You can do it with your child.
You can even do it
with your dog.
It's, uh...
can you tell us more about it?
Sure. Yeah. Um,
stand-up paddle boarding is
the fastest-growing water sport
in the world.
We know that.
What is--what is your product?
Um, we--we developed a brand
of stand-up paddle boards.
The tower brand, uh, exudes sort
of an active, social beach vibe.
You know, we produce and sell
boards, paddles,
and accessories,
and we sell them direct to
consumers through our web site.
How much have you sold?
We've sold $100,000.
Over what period of time?
Uh, in about four months.
What does the board sell for
and what does the paddle
sell for?
Okay, our boards sell
for, uh, $600.
Basically in this industry
right now, um,
paddle boards cost $1,200
to $1,600.
They're t--sold through
a traditional retail Channel.
Has everybody heard
of this sport before today?
Sure.
Oh, yeah.
I-I do it all the time.
Okay, so--
the paddle board Business
is--is going boom.
Some people on the panel
May not understand
all the cardio benefits of this.
Would you mind
if your lovely assistant
demonstrates exactly
how this works?
Where do you stand? How does
the paddle work?
If you don't mind.
You--you paddle like this.
And there's a health benefit
to this.
I noticed.
They say that one hour
of stand-up paddle Boarding
is equivalent--
in terms of exercise--
to eight hours of Surfing.
Convince me why your business is
gonna be participating
in this market
and why it's worth $1.5 million
today.
Sure. It's--it's on, uh,
and those sales are over
the past four months.
4 months ago, we did $3,000
in sales for that month.
Last month we did $35,000.
We're basically selling
a $1,200 board in a $600 dress.
So is the advantage I have
as an investor
I can get on the ground floor
of a low-cost provider
to the paddle board industry?
It--it is the low-cost provider
in a sense.
It's not the cheapest board
on the market.
(Robert) Right. There's cheaper
boards than 600 bucks.
There's cheap--well,
there's boards that are
about in that price range.
They're sold through
the TRADITIONAL retail channels.
So we're skipping all of that.
Now the direct Sales are
coming from your web site?
Coming from the--the web site.
And how are you
building traffic?
This is basically
the--the expertise
that we bring to the table.
I mean, sort of the pixie dust
that we have is
I'm an internet
marketing expert.
So what does it cost you
to acquire a customer that buys
a board? Do you have any idea?
Uh, yeah.
It doesn't cost us Anything.
Uh, we just started
this business.
I've--I've developed it myself.
I've developed the web site.
Um, like I was saying,
I'm an internet marketing expert
with about 12 years
of Experience.
Well, then you know
that answer's crap.
You know it costs you something
to get--get a customer
to come to your site.
Uh, you--you would be shocked.
You--you would be shocked.
Well, I'm going to be
if you tell me it's zero
because I don't believe you.
If you google "Best,
you know, paddle boards,"
We're not number one in google.
We're three of the top four.
Let's talk about money
for a second.
Sure.
You're telling me for $150,000,
I get 10%.
That means the value
of the company that you want me
to buy into is $1.5 million.
Sure.
I have $1.5 million, okay?
Okay.
Now why don't I take
some of my $1.5 million,
if I want to be
in this business,
and go to your manufacturer
and create Mr. Wonderful boards?
Then I set up a Web site,
I get a couple of geeks,
and they write the code for me
and I also have a web site.
How are you gonna sell it?
Are you gonna go through--
I'm gonna do
the same thing you do.
Direct.
I'm gonna pay nothing
for marketing
because you're telling me
I don't have to.
Okay.
What do I need you for is
my question.
Well, um, to--to basically--
to do that,
to do the zero marketing thing,
you're gonna need
to--to hire somebody
to get to the top of google.
And guys like me--
we're not cheap.
Yeah, but I can hire those guys
all day long.
You really think that none of us
up here have guys like--
I have plenty of guys
like this.
I do, too.
There's nothing that I can't
do myself. I don't need you.
Six months--
time-out. Time-out.
I can't hear another word.
Okay.
You're probably the worst
presenter I've ever met.
Oh, come on.
Just 'cause you don't get it
doesn't mean
he's a bad presenter.
Yes. No, I get it all.
Come on.
I've built so many web sites,
I've hired guys like this,
and you know what?
You talk like all of 'em.
You know they're like?
Leprechauns.
They come in the night.
They talk ibber-gibberish.
You don't get
what they're saying.
They run away with your wallet.
That's what happens, right.
Believe me. I've hired
so many guys like you.
That's ridiculous.
Barbara, that's ridiculous.
Well,
it's--it's not ridiculous.
I've had very bad experience
With guys that talk like this.
I don't get it.
I-I definitely failed to get
my--my message across to you.
Whoa, whoa, Whoa. Yeah, you have
failed to get your message
across, and I'm listening
with Both ears wide open.
I really am, okay?
Okay. I appreciate that,
Barbara.
You know what
I think you should do?
I think that you should stick
with being a nerd.
I'm out.
Don't listen to a word
she said.
Listen, I get your presentation,
but when I'm an investor
in something,
I want there to be something
proprietary about it
that at least I have a chance
when a competitor comes up,
that I can pour some boiling oil
on them...
Yeah.
But I can't do that here because
anybody can do what you do.
I gotta tell you,
I love the sport. I really do,
because it makes old guys
like me think we're cool.
But your valuation is not cool--
not $1.5 million today.
I'm out.
Basically, the bicycle for water
was invented
about the same time that
the--the biggest social network
in the world was invented.
And in that time, they've--
they've amassed, you know,
500 million Users. Correct?
The number of bicycles
in the world is 1 billion--
twice the amount
of the number of cars.
This is basically
a bicycle for the water.
Oh, my god. I have a headache.
Okay, I don't think
you understand
what we can't get over.
We can't get over
you've been
in this business three months,
there's nothing proprietary
about it,
you are valuing the business
at $1.5 million.
The problem is when
a magician starts to believe
his own tricks,
that becomes the problem,
and with that said, I'm out.
Okay. Thanks
for the consideration.
Um, so you're still in it,
mark.
I think--I think you
totally understand
sort of
the specialized expertise
that goes into a business
like this.
Is anybody else still in?
I'm still in. I'm still in.
I'm trying to--I'm trying to--
you know what I'm trying to do?
Because your--your presentation
is so different...
yeah, I know.
I'm not saying it's bad
or Good.
I'm just saying it's different.
I'm trying to structure the deal
that makes sense for me,
because I'm interested in you.
You're interesting, okay?
Okay.
So I'm thinking to myself,
why don't I give you $150,000
for 50% of this entity,
and I'd like to sell
other stuff.
And I'd want to get my cash back
though,
so I want a 10% cash royalty
on everything you sell.
So I'm getting a check
every month,
right off the top.
And if you need more money,
I'll give you more money.
But I want to be
a 50/50 partner.
Sure.
How deep does that well go?
Well, I don't know. You have
to dream up the products.
You call me up, say, "Hey,
daddy, I got a new idea."
I say "I don't care."
I want to be your Banker.
(Robert) That's exactly
what you're doing.
(Kevin) I just want
to give you some cash.
I-I think it's interesting,
but I've--I've--honestly,
you guys, this business is
an $11 million business
in a few years.
(speaks indistinctly)
Ah, look,
this is today's business.
Don't you have any other ideas?
This is an opportunity cost
for me. You're saying--
don't you have any other ideas
on what to sell?
I do. I have three
other business plans
that are
$50 million business plans.
Welcome home, son.
(laughs)
I have plenty of money.
That's not a problem.
I-I respect that offer,
but I told you earlier
in the presentation,
you can't hire guys like me.
We work for ourselves.
Sure, I can.
I'm doing it right now.
We--we can--we can call
our own shots. I mean--
I want to buy 50%
of your company for $150,000.
You want to buy 50% of me
is what you're saying.
Well, what's the difference?
What are you guys talking about?
What are you--
I don't know.
He's plain impossible.
What are you guys doing?
Give the guy an ANSWER--
YES or no?
♪♪
Daymond, Barbara, and Robert
are out,
but Kevin O'Leary
has made an offer.
So?
No, I-I can't accept that offer.
I'm--I'm sorry.
All right, I'm out.
(mark) Good!
(Robert) Mark, you got...
now let the people who know
what they're talking about
talk, right?
You got
a captive audience here.
What I see here is that you're
starting this business
to get it to a point--
because it's
such an ENORMOUS marketplace--
where you can flip it.
right? And once we flip that
and you can take that cash,
you put some in your pocket,
then you go look
for another business
and do the exact same thing.
That's right.
So I'm willing to give you
$150,000
for 30% of the company,
but the contingency is
that any future companies
that you go into,
I get the first right of refusal
so that I don't build this
for you and then you
take the money and run.
Okay. Okay.
And so you get
the first right of refusal
on me raising money
on other companies.
On any other companies.
'cause if we're--
if we're successful on this,
right,
I want to be your partner there
because it's, you know, it takes
people to work together,
and I'm not gonna be greedy.
Yeah.
You can have more than half
of the company...
Yeah.
And then, you know,
and then in--in True candor,
if there's a big enough hit,
the amount of money
we're gonna negotiate, and if it
takes a lot more capital,
I'll get more of the company,
right?
Yeah. E-e-exactly.
I mean, it's not--
I don't see the difference.
There's no set percentage
for--
I see no difference
to what I offered you.
(mark) There's
a huge difference.
I think the difference is, uh,
you know, Mr. Wonderful,
I think--I think
he--he understands it more.
He actually called you
Mr. Wonderful.
No, I get it, too,
but I'm willing to go to 25%.
Same deal. Same deal. 25%.
So we're not--we don't have
a lot of time
to mess around, Stephan.
So you just gotta make your--
make a de-decision.
I'm not gonna sit here and get
into a back and forth with
not-so-Mr. Wonderful, right?
(laughs)
I-I like your attitude,
and I think--I think you--
I think you get it,
and I'm--$150,000 is way less
than I should take
for 30% of this company,
and I--
you're gonna realize that
in about two years.
What could be a better figure?
But I'm gonna make my money
on the back end.
I like your deal, mark.
I like your deal.
Right. Right. Let's do it.
Let's do it.
(Robert) so?
Whoo! Whoa.
Did not see that coming.
I did not
see that coming.
I appreciate it.
This was--this was
a lot of fun with you guys.
Thank you.
It's a pleasure.
(laughs)
Oh, my gosh.
That was a r--that was
a rough start, right?
Did you see that coming?
I didn't see that coming.
That's a generous offer.
But you know what?
You didn't see it coming because
That's the way I played it.
You know, you bought his brain.
I'm a business builder.
I take small things
and make them great things.
♪♪
Earlier this season,
Rick Hopper
made a deal with Lori
for his magnetic Holder
for glasses.
I'll get this on tv.
I'll make you a millionaire.
Lori, you got a deal.
I'd love to do this.
Great.
Congrats, Lori.
Great idea.
Very cool, Rick.
Let's see what he's up to now.
♪♪
Eight weeks ago,
I make a deal with Lori Greiner
on "Shark tank"
And here we are at qvc
Selling my product
to millions of people.
Lori. Hi.
The minute Rick Walked
into the shark tank
and I saw his product,
I knew it was a hero,
and I was going to get it
into my show on qvc.
I'm so excited.
This is going to be wonderful.
I'm a little nervous.
She's about to launch this thing
to millions of people.
♪♪
You know I wear readers.
I've talked about it a lot.
This is the best idea.
And the magic
is right here--
there's a super-strong Magnet.
Look at that.
Whoo-Hoo-HOO-hoo-hoo!
Whoo!
We just sold out
5,000 sets in Minutes.
That equates to
$100,000 worth of readerests.
I'm so excited
for you!
When I was watching the screen,
and somebody told me,
"It's gonna sell out.
It's gonna sell out,"
I'm like--my goosebumps
got bigger,
and I-I'm not a very
emotional guy,
but I seriously, I--my tears
started coming to my eyes
because I knew this is--
this is the big opportunity
for this product.
You know what we have to do?
What--w-what's next?
We have to make more!
♪♪
Next up is
Nick and penilopee Larosa
with a quick fix
to an age-old Problem.
Hello, Sharks.
We're Nick and penilopee Larosa
from tampa, Florida.
Our product
is the instant lifts.
We're seeking $100,000
for 25% of our business.
We have solved
the problem of cellulite
and sagging skin for women.
The instant lift
are clear dermahesives
that go on the skin,
and it lifts
and repositions the skin,
and it makes everything
look firm and tight.
They go on five
different body parts.
They hide discreetly
under clothes.
Here's a typical
flabby arm.
You take the product...
apply it like this...
here's my before,
(Robert laughs)
Here's my after.
See?
Here's my before,
there's my After.
Here's a pair of thighs
all dimply with Cellulite.
Before
our instant lifts...
after Our instant lifts.
Isn't that great?
And then watch this thigh
lift right up.
Isn't that amazing?
And it goes underneath shorts,
and makes you look like you got
a nice, tight leg again.
(laughter and groans)
Barbara's been doing this
with Masking tape forever.
(laughter)
Well, ours is
a little special.
This is not just
a piece of tape.
We've got
the formula developed,
we have a design
developed.
But--but doesn't--after you wear
it for a couple of hours,
it starts to loosen up
and starts looking like
chewed bubble gum
in a plastic bag?
No. Absolutely not.
We live in
Hot, sweaty tampa.
If it can last through
one of my tampa hot flashes,
it can last all day.
And how long does it last?
If you tape yourself up
on a new day...
12 to 15 hours a day.
How long?
It--you get one use
out of it,
but it will last
12 to 15 hours.
Are you guys selling any
right now?
Yes. We have been selling these
for about five months.
We've done about 75,000
between us and the website
We're just getting started.
75,000 units
or $75,000?
Dollars.
And how much is each unit?
5 pair for $19.95.
Why is it you haven't
made it for the Chin?
Uh, we're--we're here to talk
about this one today.
(Robert) no?
We have other products.
Yeah.
But it would all be
part of the same company?
(Nick and penilopee) No.
Oh.
They're
different patents.
Different things.
But you're selling me
everything?
I'm selling you this.
(mark) No.
(daymond) Nope.
(Kevin) Well, good to know.
Five body parts--
basically, from here down
we can cover it.
So you're selling me
below the face?
(laughter)
Yeah.
But above the face...
that's a different meeting.
How are you gonna
manage your time, then?
I mean, if I give you
all this money,
I don't want you
working on anything
but what makes me money.
So how are you gonna work
on two different products,
or potentially,
even more?
We can get it handled.
Piece of Cake.
No, there's no such thing
as "Getting it handled,
piece of cake."
No, they're two entirely
different categories,
so it wouldn't be--
there wouldn't be a conflict.
But it's the same product.
Agree with me--it's the same
product. It's the same idea.
I don't agree with you.
It's the same area
of bus--
from a consumer perspective,
it's the same product.
Technically,
it might be different,
but if I'm thinking,
you know what?
My Butt--Butt and my arms
need a lift,
and, boy, these guys do
a great job.
I want a Chin lift or
whatever else it might be,
an eye lift, I'm gonna come
to the same company,
because of the money spent
on branding this product.
We might be able to work
something out like that.
Then we could sell them
the smooth sleepers
and things like that.
We can talk about that, sure.
We--we have--
well, hurry up
and start talking.
We have multiple...
we have multiple
products on the market.
Well, we have
a lot here to sell.
Yeah?
We do.
We have a lot here
to start off with.
Okay, well, I'm gonna
start off with this--I'm out.
We--we discovered that you've
got another product
in the same category.
Everybody up here
feels uncomfortable with that,
because, as Mr. Cuban
pointed out,
you're not working
100% for me anymore
if I'm an investor.
There's something
in the back of your mind
that's using up your time
for somebody else,
and I can't live with That.
So, you know, you gotta
get to a place...
okay. Let's put
the smooth sleepers in.
Where you're throwing that
on the table.
Let's put
the smooth sleepers in.
No, the smooth sleepers are not
what they're talking about.
They're talking
about the face Lifts.
That's not ours.
It's not ours, yes.
But wait! There's more!
(Robert) What's the other
product we don't know about?
This is being Very secretive--
Well, the first product
she invented...
almost like this product,
you know? When you...
there's no secret
about it.
But we have a life outside of
these lifts, it's True.
I have five inventions,
several patents...
right there, guys.
Guys...
you just proved
Mr. Cuban's point.
The fact is, you just--
you just made my point. Yeah.
But...
yeah, but you have all
these other products.
But we would shelve that
for this.
You just said, "I have
another part of my life."
We do.
Would you give anybody money
Who would then,
when you call them back
about the money, they go,
"Oh, I was doing the other
stuff. I got another life, too."
Would you really do that?
No, we are actually not
that kind of people.
We're very focused.
But you just said that.
No, I'm telling you
we have other products.
But if you and I
partnered together,
this would become
our priority.
This pitch is really like
that woman I meet
and I take home,
and she rips that tape off,
and her bingo wings just
hang out all over the place.
(Robert) Why is it called
a "Bingo wing"?
'cause when a-a grandma
is playing bingo,
and she goes, "Bingo!"
and her wing goes...
(laughter)
I didn't think
you were so worried
about some other product.
Here's the crazy thing--
I was actually very interested.
I think there's
a big market for this.
But you're creating
a new market.
You're creating a brand
and you're creating
a category.
And the category is--use tape
to Make yourself look thinner.
Right.
I just don't understand how
you can break up body parts.
Let's sell Barbara
the shoulders.
Let's sell daymond the legs.
Let's sell Kevin the boobs.
Well, you have everything here
except the Face.
Right.
(laughs)
And that is
a different part.
(mark) But not from
our perspective.
Guys, there's too much confusion
for me. Like I said...
no, no...
from a strategic
perspective,
you made some choices--
maybe not the right ones--
so I'm out.
You're not making any money now
if you normalized your salaries.
You're not worth $400,000.
I'm out.
Okay.
I don't think this strategy
sticks together for me.
It's very confusing.
I'm out.
Guys, you have
one last chance
to pitch your
bingo wings--Barbara.
There's a lot of women out there
that won't even wear shorts.
I believe you.
Here's what I think.
What are you doing, Barbara?
I'm a woman, certainly,
and I could envision a lot
of women using this product.
But the money
is just too much
for the very little bit
of sales you have.
I'm out.
I think we're all out.
It's done.
(Barbara) it is pricy,
I have to say.
I don't get it. I think
it's a big disappointment
when you finally untape
your woman
and you see
what you actually got.
(laughs)
(high-pitched voice)
"Bingo!"
I wish we could get in there
and do it again
and just not bring up
the face tape
and--and just focus on
the--the arm lifts
and the body Lifts.
♪♪
Next into the tank
is Gary dejohn,
with a product designed
for wine lovers.
Hi. My name is Gary dejohn
and I'll be your server
tonight,
and I am so tired
of saying that.
I have developed a product that
is going to revolutionize
the way
we serve wine worldwide.
I'm asking for
a $75,000 investment
for 30% equity in my company,
vinamor.
Wine is a living organism.
When it is bottled,
the winemaker
basically puts it to sleep,
and it needs to be
woken up before tasting.
People are continually let down
by the Harsh tannins and acidity
associated with red wine,
so they've turned to this--
a traditional wine decanter.
Take the entire contents
of a bottle,
pour it in the top...
it's messy.
Now here's the hard part.
You wait about an hour.
My product does this
in just seconds.
This is how it works--
the vinamor sits neatly
in the top of any wine glass.
As you pour the wine through the
strainer and over the ball,
it exposes
all the wine to air,
gives it the most amount
of surface area possible,
and allows the wine
to breathe.
Every glass of wine poured
at home or in restaurants
needs to be poured
through a vinamor
to give it
the proper taste.
With a $75,000 investment,
I will be able to manufacture
on a much grander scale
than I currently can,
and it will also kick-start
my marketing campaign
to get these into every house,
every restaurant,
and every Liquor store
nationwide.
Now Kevin would like
to come up here
and test taste
a couple of these for me.
I'm gonna pour one
in a regular wine glass
and one with the vinamor.
All right.
This one's been aerated?
Absolutely.
Yeah, it works.
(laughs)
I'll just keep this.
Sure.
(laughter)
Um, Gary...
yes, sir.
There are many aerators
on the market.
There are.
I own them all.
And, uh, this is
a novel design, obviously,
but it's not unique.
It's also a little more delicate
'cause it's glass, is it not?
It is a little bit
more delicate,
however, we can make it out of
a really nice acrylic
and make it
a little bit more durable.
But tell me
what the difference
between the aerators
I already have and this--
they both aerate wine
very successfully.
They do. However,
the other ones
can't measure
a glass of wine.
So when you're looking at
a restaurant scenario...
so you're saying
you tell the staff
to pour to
the middle of the ball?
Right. Absolutely.
It cuts your
overpouring costs,
and, I mean,
it's dual-Purpose.
Cuts your overpouring costs,
gets every ounce of profit
out of every bottle
at every Restaurant.
Gary, can I see it?
Sure.
Thank you.
Mark.
It's clever.
Thank you, Gary.
You're welcome.
So are you seeing this
for probably more high-end
restaurants that have a cellar?
Not necessarily,
but you can brand this.
When you look at a store
like the Olive garden,
you could basically put
the Olive garden logo
inside the ball
and then sell them
as a retail item.
Gary, do you have
any sales today?
Um, not much. I've sold
about 1,000 of them.
And to whom?
Uh, direct to consumer.
I actually--I work
in a restaurant.
Uh, that's where
the idea came from.
And pretty much every one
of my tables that drinks wine
takes one home.
And what do they sell for?
$40.
And what's your cost?
$20.
That's way too high
for this.
Absolutely.
It is way too high.
And that's why
I need an investment,
to take this overseas and make
as much profit as possible.
How much I know
about wine, or care...
Mm-Hmm.
Wouldn't even fit into
one of those glasses. I'm out.
What's your plan
for distribution for this?
Basically, if I can get them
into every restaurant
that serves wine,
then we've got free salespeople
in the restaurant.
Restaurants don't sell
wine Apparel.
Yet.
It's complicated--
the Design.
Who designed that?
I did.
Gary, what gave you the idea?
Um, it's actually a statistic
that in restaurants,
if you finish your first glass
of wine before your entree,
the chances of you ordering
a second glass of wine
are 78% higher.
So now you've
increased your sales
at every Single table
That's drinking Wine.
Gary, I don't know anything
about this market,
so I can't help you in this.
I'm out.
Hey, Gary, I hate
to join the chorus,
but, you know, I have a rule--
I don't trust any bottle of wine
that costs more than $5.
And so...
try that. Try that.
Put a $5 bottle of wine
through there,
and it'll make it taste like
a $50 bottle of wine.
I'm a beer drinker,
not a wine drinker at all.
So, I-I really couldn't help.
So for that reason,
I'm out.
Gary, I think there is
a market for the product,
but it's just not something
that I want to invest in.
I'm out.
Only the wino's left.
So, Gary, you know,
I take the product Works.
Thank you.
It's not unique.
And the only way
to make this work
is for you to license this.
It's not a project I want
to take on, my friend.
I'm sorry. I'm out.
Are you sure?
I am sure.
I am sure. The only thing
you've differentiated--
'cause I know every aerator
on the market--
is this measurement concept
for the restaurant industry,
which is a small subset
of the total aeration market.
The thing is, I like
to go make money
so I can buy
$2,000 bottles of wine.
Right.
And I drink the whole thing
with a straw.
I'll do it for 45%.
Gary, I have to pick
my battles,
and, um, use my time wisely.
I'm sorry, my friend.
Anybody else want back in?
(laughs)
(mark) smart man.
Barbara?
No, thank you.
No?
Mark, I'm gonna go put on
my nowitzki jersey.
I wish I could.
(laughs)
I give you a little money,
you give me a little money.
You know, I got
fubu boxers on.
If I knew this business,
you'd be a great partner,
and that would be
a great product.
I-I just can't help you.
Okay. Well,
thank you for your time.
Go get 'em, Gary.
Good luck.
(Robert) Love that guy.
Good guy.
Small niche product.
The guy had
the hustle and the heart.
It doesn't make me feel happy
that they weren't interested,
but they're not
the only investors out there.
And when I sell
for $40 million next year,
then I can come back
and laugh at them.
♪♪
Next into the tank
is aviv grill
with a company focusing on
high-tech solutions
for music education.
Hi. My name is aviv grill.
I am the C.E.O. Of miso media,
and today I'm going to show you
why our company is going
to fundamentally change
digital music education.
I'm looking for $300,000
for 5% of the company.
Oh.
(Kevin) Miso Baby.
Hope you have some sales.
Me so greedy.
We--we'll get into that.
Yeah, I bet we will.
(laughs)
Um, so there are a lot
of different aspects
to the company
that we have.
The first Commercial application
that we had
launched in June.
And it's an ipad and iphone app
called miso music.
And it teaches people
how to play, uh, the guitar,
ukulele, Bass,
banjo and Mandolin.
Uh, and I'm gonna
show you that right now.
So, uh, there are a couple
different ways
that the app can be used.
Uh, let's say you don't have
a real instrument.
You can use a virtual instrument
that we have in the app.
I'm gonna use
a koaloha ukulele.
You wanna select
right here.
And I'm gonna play a song
that I really enjoy
called "Be ok"
By Ingrid Michaelson.
So the way that this works
is the notes scroll down
the face of the guitar
similar to a game
like guitar hero.
And when it hits
the yellow tempo bar,
you're supposed to play.
(plays melody)
But Let's say I want to do it
using a real instrument.
We have, uh,
these adapters,
which allow you to plug your
guitar directly into the ipad.
And I'm gonna play
the same song,
except this time I'm going
to grab the ukulele.
So I'm going to come
over to here,
and it should show up
on the back.
(plays melody)
So I can't really
do this song Justice.
Uh, so I've actually
brought with me
Ingrid Michaelson to perform
her hit song herself.
(laughs)
Oh, my gosh.
Great.
So can you come out here?
♪ Ta-da ♪
(laughs)
Hi.
(Barbara and Kevin) Hi.
(daymond) Hey.
(playing "Be ok")
♪ I just want to be ok,
be ok, be ok ♪
oh, wow.
♪ I just wanna be okay today ♪
(mark) Yeah. Whoo!
♪ Open me up
and you will see ♪
♪ I'm a gallery
of broken hearts ♪
♪ and let me hold
my broken parts ♪
♪♪
♪ I just want to be ok ♪
whoo!
Yeah!
(applause)
Wow.
Nice job.
I'm in.
So the app makes me
sing and play like her?
I come with the app, Yeah.
You do? I'm in!
(daymond) I'm in,
I'm in, I'm in.
(laughs)
Aviv, so very smart
to bring Ingrid here
to help sell your product.
Thank you.
She's also an advisor
to the company.
And damn, she can sing.
What's your background?
Are you a musician?
My Dad's a recording engineer,
my mom's an opera Singer.
Uh, I worked in entertainment.
So this is your first...
it's my first
tech Company. Yeah.
So, uh, yeah.
We debuted this technology.
Afterwards, we closed
an INVESTMENT round
led by google ventures.
What percentage of investment
did google take?
Uh, google did $100,000.
Uh, we had people LIKE
Justin Timberlake
Come on board, as well,
uh, in the company.
Oh, drop a few names, maybe?
(laughs)
Let's talk about
a couple of things here--
do I have to be
a hardcore musician?
Can I just be a Hacker?
What am I?
Who's your customer?
Well, uh, you know,
it's both.
We want to be able
to target the casual musician,
people who just want
to learn more music.
You know, sheet music
sells in this country.
It's a $600 million a year
industry.
It's $600 million?
In the United States alone.
Are you selling--
are you selling scripts?
Selling sheet music?
Yes, absolutely.
So we have, you know,
a whole store
where you can do
in-app purchases.
What are the sales
today, aviv?
So in the past month,
we've had 80,000 downloads.
So when you say "Download,"
what are we downloading?
So the app--
the ipad app.
Ipad app, okay.
And the app I'm downloading
was the one that'll let you
play the Music.
Exactly.
And how much is it?
Uh, the app is free.
How do you get revenue
off that,
or is there
any revenue today?
There is.
So we have
in-app purchases.
So you can buy sheet music
from a variety of artists.
We have a huge catalog
of sheet music
which is growing every day.
We're converting
about 8% of our users
into paying customers,
which is...
and what--what are
they paying for,
the sheet music
or an upgraded app?
They're paying
for the sheet music.
So we're looking
to not just have customers
Come on board
and buy one song.
We're looking
to retain customers,
to have people
who come back regularly...
hmm.
And buy music from us.
So--so the idea is,
you're making an app,
it's cool, it's fun,
people come to it
as a community,
and then, when they're there,
you're going to
sell them sheet music.
Exactly.
So you just found
a clever way
to go after
a traditional market.
Exactly, and we've also created
some pretty profound technology.
But you're not gonna sell that.
It's just--it's all
part of the packaging.
Exactly. So, you know,
digital sheet Music
distribution
has not been
particularly successful.
And the reason--
Well, it's not sexy.
You've made it sexy.
Exactly.
Now you're valuing
the company at $6 million.
Yes.
Where are you getting
that value from?
Well, I mean, most people
look at a company
and you base valuation
on traction or technology.
What was the last round
of investment done at?
Uh, the last one was done
at a $3 million valuation.
So why... why do I have
to pay twice as much?
I mean, we have
a lot more software.
A huge amount
more software.
When was the last round done?
Uh, the last round
closed in december.
So we're talking
six months later
and the company's
doubled in value?
Yes.
Throw me a bone, miso.
Why would you say that it
doubled in value in six months?
Yeah.
How would you justify that?
Well, I mean, I think that
the second
that Justin Timberlake
and google came on board,
the value raised.
Does it work
for every instrument,
or it's Only
stringed instruments?
Well, this app is
only stringed instruments.
We're actually working on
standard music notation
right now, which will go
across all platforms.
And our note detection
technology
works across
all instruments.
(mark) and what did you say
your revenue was?
Uh, so we've had--
for the sheet music sales,
we've had 35,000 downloads.
Uh, it equates to about
$40,000, uh, in sales.
So this is why it doesn't
make sense here.
You have incredible artists.
You also have google
and people who have money.
Right?
Mm-hmm.
You have something out
for $1.2 million,
and you're insulting us
with an offer of 5%.
You don't really want
to make a deal here, do you?
No, I would love to.
I-I think that you guys are all
really brilliant investors.
And I'd love
to have you guys on board.
Then why is it 5%?
There is something
fishy here,
because you have
everything you need.
♪♪
All the sharks are still in,
but daymond is suspicious
about Aviv's offer.
So this is why
it doesn't make sense here.
You have incredible artists.
You also have google
and people who have money,
right?
Mm-hmm.
You have something out
for $1.2 million.
And you're insulting us with
an offer of 5%.
You don't really want to
make a deal here, do you?
No, I would love to.
I-I think that you guys are all
really brilliant investors,
and I'd love to have
you guys on board.
Then why is it 5%?
There is something
fishy here,
because you have
everything you need.
And I don't want
to waste my time,
so I'm out.
May I? I just want to clear
the deck a little bit here.
I've been burned
by Technology businesses
many times before,
and they go through money
WAY too fast.
I'm out.
Okay. So let me try to
understand exactly what you own.
Yeah.
Right. Did you develop
the software involved here?
Yes.
Okay.
Everything's been
developed ourselves.
Do you own the I.P.
On all the code?
Uh, we do.
I look at this
as, like, an option.
You've got an interesting
platform here.
I have no idea if
you'll be successful or not.
But so far,
it looks pretty good.
I think that We're going
to be the leaders
in Digital music education.
I mean, it's been a field
that hasn't had success.
But there hasn't really
been an interactive way
for people to be able
to learn music online.
Let me throw
something out here.
'cause to me, you know,
I-I like guitar,
I like Ingrid. I like you.
Google options you--they give
you 100 grand just to say,
"Who the hell knows What's gonna
happen with this guy?
Let's throw some money at him."
That's how I feel.
So I'll offer you $100,000,
which is an option amount,
but I want 3 1/3%.
In other words,
it's the same valuation
as the last round.
Will somebody else--
he's asking for $300,000.
You gotta stick
with $300,000.
I have $100,000 I want
to throw at him. That's all.
He has to raise
the other $200,000.
Oh, no!
What a problem.
(laughter)
So you want the same value
as before,
and you want aviv
to go out and...
You're a smart guy, Robert.
Well, you want aviv to go out
and get the other $200,000
from another two sharks?
That's why they call it
work, my friend.
So you understand what
he's saying to you right now?
Yeah.
Yeah, he's a smart guy.
Who's left on this deal?
Mark, you're in still?
I know he's smart.
I'm still--
I'm still evaluating.
I mean, I'm not really
interested
in doing it
at the last valuation.
I mean, we have other money
on the table, as well.
So this is--honestly, it has
less to do...
Well, that's a bit
of a problem.
'cause I didn't need
to go in with Kevin.
I was gonna offer you
the entire $300,000
if you'd consider the same
value as you took initially.
I-I mean...
so $300,000 for 10%.
Yeah. We have money
on the table.
The reason why I want
you guys to come on board
is 'cause I want
strategic investors.
Well, if you have money
on the table,
why would you be here?
Because I want you guys.
Okay, well you got me.
$300,000 for 10%.
I'm having a problem
having to pay twice as much
as some guys did, basically,
when you closed it
probably 90 days ago.
Um, I mean, I can do...
I can do the $300,000...
for 7% equity.
Which...
you're only
300 basis points away
from where We need to be.
Uh...
the Real issue behind this is if
I lower the VALUATION too much,
it--it's gonna hurt me
on the other end
while I'm raising
the rest of this money.
I offered you
the $300,000 for 10%.
Um...
aviv, I'm not gonna
match that offer.
I'm out.
With Three sharks out,
Kevin and mark
are aviv's last chances
to make a deal.
Aviv, what is the thing
that's gonna accelerate you
to where it's
a very big enterprise?
Well, music education is
a $9 billion a year industry.
Right.
That's a--
that's a huge market.
Do you see being able to charge
for a premium version
and upsell people?
That's something that
we had actually talked about.
We've always stated
that the app is free
for a limited time
when we first launched.
Right.
Uh, so yeah,
I-I would--I definitely
am leaving it open to that.
Yeah, I-I've got
a better understanding now.
So what I'm willing to do
is the $300,000
for 8%.
Are you doing
the whole $300,000 yourself?
I'll do the whole $300,000
myself, Yeah.
It's a no-brainer.
Okay. I'll do the same terms.
I'll do $100,000 of it.
If he doesn't wanna let me in,
that's cool, too.
But you may wanna have
as many sharks as you can.
Particularly ones that
can actually play something.
(laughs) Hey, I actually
play a few instruments.
Maybe not well, but I play.
Not well. I-I heard you.
(laughs)
I'll do half of it.
Obviously, I'd love
to do a deal with you.
You don't need Kevin.
You'd rather work
with me...
because I understand it,
and I'm not gonna
be beating you up all the time.
We have a deal?
You got it.
Awesome.
Appreciate it, aviv.
Thank you.
Yeah, Pleasure.
Congratulations.
Thanks a lot.
(Barbara) Well,
what happened to you?
I guess I got cut out.
The undertaker
gets Buried.
That's okay.
You got ran over
by a bus.
The undertaker
got buried.
I still have my cash.
She was great,
by the way.
She was.
You know what
the best part is?
He's smart, and I
don't have to babysit.
I think it's a good deal.
I am so stoked!
Oh, my god!
This is exactly
the deal that we wanted.
And I-I'm just giddy.
I'm so happy.